im Ahrtal 17 Monate nach der Flut wie
geht es hier voran ich bin wütend ich
bin enttäuscht ich verliere einfach das
Vertrauen
die größte Versicherung die mir hier im
Aartal hatten waren zuerst die
freiwilligen Helfer sonst wäre mir nie
mehr auf die Füße gekommen
wie es dann ist wenn man im Haus ist
wenn der erste Regen wiederkommt das
kann ich noch gar nicht beurteilen
wir sind für euch unterwegs an der aaar
Kameramann Christoph Tim und ich Marion
Geiger die Reporterin wenn man gegen die
Natur arbeitet wird man mit diesem Fluss
nicht zurechtkommen das wird sich über
kurze lang rächen
[Musik]
Bad Neuenahr-Ahrweiler das urbane Herz
des katastrophengebiets in der Flut
meterhoch unter Wasser
in den Gassen der Altstadt deinen
Nebeneinander von saniert und kaputt
wir treffen parthena Amanatidis
für mich ist es irgendwie erschreckend
dass es mittlerweile Alltag geworden ist
dass ich in in der Geisterstadt wohne
oder in generell dass es irgendwie so
normal für uns geworden ist dass alles
irgendwie kaputt ist nicht schön und
Baulärm dreckig leer stehen
parthena und ihre Schwester führen das
Restaurant La Perla es war in der Flut
letztes Jahr schwer zerstört worden die
Familie nicht gegen Elementarschäden
versichert
monatelang haben sie geschuftet um
wieder aufmachen zu können
Patina bekam private Spenden auf
staatliche Hilfe wartet sie immer noch
es macht mich wütend man hat Angst man
hat sorgen
Existenzängste man hat die ganze Zeit
das Gefühl man macht und man macht man
ist wie so ein Hamster im Laufrad und
irgendwie kommt keine Ruhe rein in die
Situation und man fühlt sich halt
einfach so ein bisschen im Stich
gelassen das Geld für den Wiederaufbau
kam vor allem von patinas Eltern deren
Ersparnissen für die Rente bis zu 80%
ihrer Kosten kann sie wieder bekommen
aus dem staatlichen Flut Hilfe vor doch
die Sache mit dem Antrag zieht sich
es ist das Gegenteil des versprochenen
schnell und unbürokratisch das Problem
ist es ist sehr zeitaufwendig alle
Sachen zusammen zu bekommen
das generell das große Zeitproblem du
bist tatsächlich auch gerade am Anfang
sehr sehr alleine gelassen worden man
hat überhaupt gar keine richtigen
Leitfaden gehabt wie macht man das jetzt
wie geht man es richtig an
hier noch ein Gutachten da noch ein
Schreiben da noch dies da das bist du
diese ganzen Sachen alleine schon mal
zusammen hast ist schon so viel Zeit
wieder in Land gelaufen dass man einfach
auch die Hoffnung verliert wenn man
nicht weiß wann geht's denn jetzt
vorwärts und es ist alles jetzt schon
komplett abgegeben seit sechs Monaten
und es ist noch keine Rückmeldung
wie lange es noch dauert ob dem Antrag
etwas fehlt sie haben nachgefragt und
stets dieselbe Antwort bekommen in
Bearbeitung
so frohpatener ist mit dem Restaurant
wieder selbst Geld zu verdienen die
33-Jährige ist erschöpft wir hatten eine
Pandemie wir haben eine Flut und jetzt
kommt direkt als nächstes die ganze
inflations- und kriegssache hinterher ja
das ist einfach ein unsagbarer Druck der
auf einem lastet und irgendwie kein
Licht am Ende des Tunnels obwohl ich
schon so weit bin ich kann schon wieder
arbeiten an der Stelle sind ganz ganz
viele Leute noch gar nicht
alle hier müssen neu klarkommen die
a-allee direkt am Fluss in Ahrweiler
hier hat Familie hosterriemenschneider
gewohnt
das Wasser stieg in der Flut rasend
schnell vom Keller über das Erdgeschoss
bis knapp unter den ersten Stock die
Eltern und ihre drei Töchter flüchteten
nach oben und wurden eingeschlossen
wir waren im Haus in der Nacht und sind
dann am nächsten Tag
raus mit gepackten Rucksäcken durch
Schlamm und Müll und Wasser noch um um
halt rauszukommen aus dem Tal
aber mir war nicht klar dass das quasi
ein Abschied ist von von unserem Haus
von unserem zu Hause
das Haus nach der Flut unbewohnbar die
Familie verlor einen großen Teil ihres
Hausrats und viele Erinnerungsstücke
umso kostbarer was ihnen vom Alten
geblieben ist die elfjährige Frieda
liebt die Weihnachtskrippe ihr Vater
konnte sie gerade noch so aus dem Keller
retten der Frosch auf dem Dach ein
familienbrauch
die Familie hat einige
übergangsquartiere hinter sich erst seit
April leben sie wieder im alten
Stadtteil
hier sind halt auch allen meine Freunde
und habe ich auch schon vorher gewohnt
und dann weiß ich halt
wo alles ist
Riemenschneiders wohnen wie vorher zur
Miete und müssen sich nicht mit
Finanzfragen zum Wiederaufbau
herumschlagen sie freuen sich
Weihnachten im neuen Zuhause feiern zu
können und doch ist die Flut für sie
nicht vorbei es braucht Zeit im neuen
Setting anzukommen
es wird besser
aber es ist wie wenn man in so einem
Würfelbecher durchgeschüttelt wird und
irgendwo anders ausgekippt wird und es
ist
ungewohnt fremd
umso wichtiger vertraute es zum ersten
Mal nach Corona und Flut ist wieder
Weihnachtsmarkt in Ahrweiler die Eltern
kaufen ein den ersten Holz Engel für
ihre neue Sammlung die alte versank in
der Flut
es sind kleine Schritte auf dem Weg zu
normal in der Stadt in der sie bleiben
wollen
gerade Innenstadt Ahrweiler da passiert
ganz viel da machen Geschäfte auf da
machen Geschäfte wieder auf da kommt das
Leben zurück
an anderen Stellen hier im Ort oder auch
an der A da ist die Veränderung so
gewaltig so diese Zerstörung dieses so
groß
das macht einen auch noch traurig es
kommen auch Zweifel manchmal dass dass
ich denke oh war das eine gute
Entscheidung das so lange aushalten zu
müssen aber
dann denke ich auch wieder es ist unser
Zuhause und es ist einfach auch wert
hier zu bleiben
und nicht das auch noch zu verlieren
dieses ich gehöre hierhin geführt
von diesem Gefühl hören wir oft viele
Betroffene erzählen uns davon
das Dorf mayschoss am Ufer der Art die
erste Häuserreihe völlig zerstört
doch ein Erdgeschoss leuchtet
Vidos Kaffee provisorisch eingerichtet
Bäckermeister Guido Ockenfels hat schon
letztes Jahr wieder eröffnet er liebt
sein Handwerk und wollte sich das von
der Flut nicht nehmen lassen hier wieder
backen seine Art dem Schicksal zu
trotzen ist eine angenehme Form der
Stress Bewältigung zu wissen man kann
seinem Beruf wieder nachgehen und man
hat halt eben auch sein Einkommen wieder
in der Flut waren Kaffee und Backstube
von der schlammigen Brühe verwüstet
worden alles Inventar die ganze Existenz
stehen kaputt
dann fingen sie einfach an aufzuräumen
die ganze Familie packte mit an und eine
Unmenge freiwilliger Helfer und
Helferinnen
ohne die sage ich jetzt mal hätten wir
das noch nie schaffen können generell
nicht
wildfremde Leute die geholfen haben
Schlamm zu schaufeln Putz abzuhauen oder
halt einfach mal jemand der zum
quatschen vorbei kam
wie du es Glück seine Maschinen in der
Backstube sind alt keine einzige musste
verschrottet werden
mein Bruder ist Maschinenbauer und ein
befreundete Elektriker die haben sich
den Maschinen angenommen und haben die
dann komplett zerlegt und dann mit alles
gegangen bei ihm gemacht repariert das
ist der Vorteil das ist noch made in
Germany Baujahr 72 sind also im Grunde
genommen
für die Gebäudesanierung ist sein
Vermieter zuständig der Schaden für wie
du dadurch beherrschbar obwohl er nicht
versichert war
im Laden gibt es jetzt wieder das volle
Sortiment die Leute in mayschoss sind
froh dass er und seine Frau Mirja
geblieben sind
hier war ja nach der Flut eigentlich gar
nichts mehr und
schon schön wenn man sich wieder frische
Brötchen holen kann das liebe ich sehr
wir haben uns einfach unglaublich
gefreut dass der Video gesagt hat wir
bleiben da besonders auf die älteren
Leute ist es glaube ich wichtig ne dass
sie immer so eine Anlaufstelle haben und
wenn man hier einen Kaffee trinken kann
auf die Schnelle super
neben dem provisorischen Verkaufsraum
liegt das alte Café dort im Obergeschoss
hat wieder mit seiner Familie gewohnt
und hier wollen sie wieder einziehen
mayschoss für Sie Heimat die Kinder sind
hier aufgewachsen dazu der etablierte
Betrieb wegziehen kann nicht in Frage
wer hätte wieder komplett neu anfangen
müssen hätte auch wieder zehn 15 Jahre
gedauert bis man wirklich wieder richtig
etabliert gewesen wäre deshalb gab es da
eigentlich so keine Überlegung zu sagen
wir brechen jetzt hier die Zelte ab wir
fühlen uns hier wohl
und deshalb haben wir gesagt wir bauen
jetzt wieder auf
an vielen Stellen am Fluss sehen wir
martialisch befestigte Ufer wir wollen
wissen was mit dem Hochwasserschutz ist
und fahren nach Altenahr hier hatte die
Flut letztes Jahr ein riesiges Loch
gerissen und eine Bundesstraße zerstört
jetzt sieht es hier aus wie am
Nürburgring die Straße neu gebaut noch
näher am Ufer als vorher
Professor Wolfgang büks forscht seit
Jahrzehnten zum Ahrtal und zeigt uns
welche Gefahr dadurch entsteht diese
Baumaßnahme ist aus Sicht des
Hochwasserschutzes eine schlichte
Katastrophe denn die a ist sehr stark
eingeengt dadurch entsteht der berühmte
Düseneffekt je enger umso schneller
fließt das Wasser und das wirkt sich auf
die unterliegenden Ortschaften natürlich
im schlimmsten Fall katastrophal aus in
der Flut hatte die a sich ausgebreitet
im Tal sich Räume genommen die als
rezensionsfläche geeignet gewesen wären
das heißt hier hätte Wasser versickern
können die Arme wäre abgebremst worden
hätte wäre es nicht
ja hier in mayschoss hat man wie an
vielen anderen Orten auch die Chance
verspielt eine retentionsfläche
herzustellen denn unmittelbar nach der
Flut war diese Fläche im Prinzip
abgetragen und jetzt hat man sie wieder
aufgeschüttet die Ufer nach Standardmaß
bereitet Standard Böschungswinkel und
wie am kurvenlineal gezogen und wieder
ist ein rezensionsfläche mehr verloren
gegangen noch so ein Düseneffekt der bei
Hochwasser gefährlich sein könnte schwer
zu verstehen warum so gebaut wird die
Menschen wohnen ja weiter nah am Wasser
fast alle Häuser im Ahrtal dürfen wieder
aufgebaut werden überall neue Sirenen um
vor der nächsten Flut rechtzeitig zu
warnen
wir fragen uns wie ist das für
Betroffene an den Ort zurückzugehen wo
sie fast ums Leben gekommen werden
Jacqueline dünker musste ihr altes Haus
abreißen sie war versichert und baut auf
dem gleichen Grundstück neu diesmal auf
einem ein Meter hohen Betonsockel
das ist auf jeden Fall ein gutes Gefühl
selbst wenn noch mal ein bisschen Wasser
kommen würde dass man trockene Füße
behält
nichtsdestotrotz es gibt viele Häuser
die auf altem Niveau geblieben sind und
man ist schon so ein bisschen auf dem
Präsentierteller also wenn ich mir
zukünftig denke dass ich auf die
Terrasse rausgehe und unsere Nachbarn
können uns auf Schritt und Tritt
verfolgen ähm aber wir verstehen uns ja
alle gut das ist etwas was man gerne
mitnimmt einfach nur der Sicherheit zu
Liebe
jacqueline's Wohnort happingen geriet in
der Flut Meter hoch unter Wasser Sie und
Ihre Partnerin kletterten aufs Dach und
wussten nicht ob das reichen würde
stundenlang saßen sie fest und
überlebten nur knapp für mich war es
tatsächlich erstmal schwer den Gedanken
wieder hierhin zurückzukommen weil die
Nacht schon tief in einem sitzt und auch
in einem arbeitet natürlich jetzt auch
nach sehr langer Zeit immer noch
deswegen habe ich von Anfang an gesagt
wenn wir zurückkommen muss irgendeine
Veränderung stattfinden wir hatten
vorher ein Satteldach wir haben jetzt
ein Flachdach ja ich sag Scherz ist
halber immer da sitzt sich besser aber
wir haben auch das Haus innen komplett
gespiegelt also alles was vorher auf der
rechten Seite war befindet sich jetzt
auf der linken Seite und alles was links
war befindet sich jetzt rechts es ist
einfach nur für mich wirklich noch mal
ein Neuanfang und dass man nicht immer
an das alte noch mal erinnert wird
seit der Katastrophe gilt ihr Wohnort
als Überschwemmungsgebiet dennoch wollen
sie bleiben auch fast alle Nachbarn und
Nachbarinnen kehren zurück
wir hoffen einfach dass wir nicht in
Vergessenheit geraten und auch diese ja
Katastrophe letztes Jahr nicht in
Vergessenheit gerät und man da akribisch
dran bleibt und weiter ja was für den
Hochwasserschutz tut
niemand weiß wann die nächste Flut kommt
im Ahrtal die Hoffnung ist dass es lange
dauert um Zeit zu haben sich
vorzubereiten